สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเจอกับครู
เอ๋และน้องเรียมที่ไหนคะที่ช่อง
comprehensible ไทยค่ะวันอะไรคะ
มาเจอกันวันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะค.ศ
2023 ค่ะเย้
12 ครึ่งเพราะว่าเรียงกับเอ๋เคยคุยกันจน
ถึง
เกือบๆ 1 ชั่วโมง
จำได้ไหม
จำได้ถ้าเราไม่ได้แบบคิดเรื่องเวลาไว้
ก็จะคุยๆๆแล้วก็เอ๊ะ
เราคุยกันมานานหรือยัง
สุดท้ายคือ 55 นาที
ช่วงนี้ไปเที่ยวบ่อยไหม
ช่วงนี้ก็ไม่ค่ะไม่บ่อยค่ะพี่เอ๋แล้วพี่
เอ๋ล่ะไปเที่ยวบ่อยไหม
ก็ไปไปใกล้ๆบ้านแต่ว่าไม่ได้ไปไกลๆนะคะไป
เที่ยวเนี่ยนักเรียนคืออย่างครูเอ๋คนไทย
น้องเรียมคนไทย
ถ้าครูเอ๋คิดอ้อไปญี่ปุ่น
ไปอเมริกา
ไปฮาวายไปมัลดีฟส์ไปเที่ยวนะคะหรือครูเอ๋
อยู่กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็คิดอ้อไปเชียงใหม่ไป
เที่ยว
เรียนอยู่มหาสารคาม
[เพลง]
ไปเที่ยวเชียงใหม่ค่ะไปเที่ยวนะนักเรียน
ก็จำเป็นเที่ยวได้นะช่วงนี้ไม่ได้ไปบ่อย
ใช่ไหมช่วงนี้พี่เอ๋ไปบ่อยแต่ว่าไปใกล้ๆ
บ้าน
ไปใกล้ๆบ้านเท่านั้นไม่ได้ไปไกลนะคะแต่ที
นี้เวลาเราจะไปเที่ยวที่ไหนอ่ะบางทีเรามี
เพื่อนมีคนรู้จัก
มีคนรู้จักเวลาที่จะไปเที่ยวสมมุติว่า
สมมุติว่าครูเอ๋ไปไม่ใช่สมมติเราไปจริงๆ
อ่ะไปใกล้ๆบ้านเขามีตลาดเป็นตลาดแล้วก็มี
อาหาร
ครูเอกก็ไปเดินแล้วก็ซื้ออาหารอันนี้ของ
ครูเอ๋อันนี้ของครูเอ๋ไปกับนักเรียนมีนัก
เรียนมาจากออสเตรเลียก็ไปด้วยกันนะคะไป
เดินเพราะว่านักเรียนกลัวจักรยาน
ต้องปั่นจักรยานด้วยหรอ
แต่ว่าถนนมันเล็กๆ
เห็นไหมคะเห็นค่ะ
โอเคนะปากกาคือแบบนี้นะคะ
จะเป็นแบบนี้
ก็คือจะมีถนนแบบนี้
แล้วก็มีรั้วนะคะแต่ไม่มีรั้วก็มีรั้ว
แต่ตรงนี้ประมาณประมาณหนึ่งจุดห้าเมตร
กว้างนะคะ
กว้างประมาณ 1.5 เมตรแล้วตรงนี้ก็มีรั้ว
แล้วข้างๆเนี่ยค่ะ
ข้างๆจะเป็นต้นไม้
แล้วก็มีน้ำ
มี
น้ำ
มีน้ำอยู่ข้างล่าง
แล้วก็
มีต้นไม้
คือทางที่เราจะถีบจักรยานจะกว้างประมาณ
1.5 เมตรเท่านั้น
แล้วมันข้างล่างเป็นน้ำไง
พาไปหลายคนละทุกคนชอบอากาศนะ
แต่ว่า
กลัวถีบจักรยาน
ล้อเล่นทำไมรู้สึกว่ามันเหมือนบางกระเจ้า
ใช่ค่ะ
ใช่
จักรยานกลายเป็นต้องนั้นไม่ใช่นั้นเดิน
แล้วก็เข็น
จักรยานดังนั้นไม่มีจักรยานดีกว่าใช่ไหม
คะ
ใช้เดินแล้วก็บางทีเรียกมอเตอร์ไซค์แต่
หลายคนก็กลัวมอเตอร์ไซค์เดินดีกว่านะคะก็
ไปเที่ยวแถวๆบางกระเจ้าแล้วก็มีอาหารก็
ครูเอ๋ก็จะแบบขอโทษค่ะ
เพื่อนบ้าน
ที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะ
ก็จะถามฮัลโหลพี่อยู่ที่นี่เอาอะไรไหม
ก็คือบางทีเพื่อนบ้านกับครูเอ๋น่ะชอบกิน
อาหาร
ชอบซื้ออาหารก็จะถามว่าเอาอะไรไหมคือถ้า
ถามว่าเอาอะไรน่ะแปลว่าเพื่อน
คือมันเป็นคอนโดเนาะแบบนี้
คอนโดห้องใกล้ๆกันน่ะ
ใช่ค่ะ
1  2  3
4  5  6 ทั้งหมดทั้งหมด 8 ชั้นนะคะ
ครูเอ๋อยู่ชั้นที่ 5 เพื่อนอยู่ชั้นที่ 2
ก็จะถามว่าเอาอะไรไหมอันนี้ก็คือว่าเขาจะ
ฝากซื้ออะไร
ก็คือเพื่อนนะคะแล้วก็ให้เงิน
ให้เงินเอ๋
อันนี้เอ๋
ให้เงินแล้วก็เอ๋ซื้อแล้วก็เอามาให้
เรียกว่าฝากซื้อนะคะ
จะฝากซื้ออะไรไหมคือถ้าโทรศัพท์เนี่ยก็
คือฝากซื้ออะไรไหมแต่ถ้าเอ๋ไม่โทรบางที
เห็นอ้ออันนี้น้องชอบรู้ว่าชอบไม่โทรซื้อ
เลย
ซื้อแล้วก็เอามาแล้วก็
แล้วก็ให้
อันนี้เป็นซื้อฝาก
มีฝากซื้อกับซื้อฝากฝากซื้อเนี่ยอันนี้
คือต้องให้เงิน
นี่เงินนะคะเงินบาทแต่มีเนี่ยซื้อฝาก
ก็คือมี
เป็นอาหาร
แล้วก็ให้
อันนี้ไม่ต้องจ่ายเงินนะคะถ้าพี่เอ๋โทรมา
หาเรียมใช่ไหมพี่เอ๋บอกว่ากำลังปั่น
จักรยานอยู่อยู่ที่บางกระเจ้า
[เพลง]
เอาเท่าไหร่
เอาเอา 2 กิโลได้ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
ได้ค่ะได้ค่ะ 2 กิโลนะใช่ค่ะใช่
1 กิโล
2 กิโลฟรี 1 กิโลก็จะได้ 3 กิโล 3 กิโล
จะถือหนักไหม 3 กิโลบางกระเจ้าใกล้ๆบ้าน
โอเคไม่เป็นไร
โอเคใช่ไหมพี่เอกเดี๋ยวนั่งแท็กซี่
อ๋อได้ค่ะถ้าอย่างนั้นเอาซื้อ 2 กิโลเนาะ
โอเคนะได้ค่ะขอบคุณค่ะฝากหน่อยนะคะพี่เอ๋
ค่ะ 100 บาทนะคะได้ค่ะขอบคุณค่ะ
อันนี้ฝากซื้อนะคะฝากซื้อคือเรียมต้องให้
เงินเอง
แต่ถ้าซื้อฝากเนี่ยเอ๋ไม่ถามครั้งนี้
เรียมฝากซื้อครั้งหน้าเอ๋จำได้อ๋อเรียน
ชอบมะม่วง
แล้วก็ปิ๊งปั๊งอยู่ไหม
อยู่ค่ะพี่เอกพี่เอกมีอะไรคะมีมะม่วง
[เพลง]
อู้
ยซื้อมะม่วงมาฝากอุ๊ยขอบคุณค่ะขอบคุณค่ะ
พี่โอเคกินให้อร่อยนะบ๊ายบาย
ขอบคุณค่ะบ๊ายบาย
อันนี้ซื้อฝากนะคะนักเรียนนี่ในประเทศไทย
แล้วใกล้ๆบ้านไม่เป็นไรนะ
เอ๋ซื้อฝากได้หรือฝากซื้อได้
พี่เอกเคยเจอไหมที่แบบ
เหมือนเรียมคุยโทรศัพท์กับพี่เอ๋แล้ว
เรียมก็แบบพี่เอซื้อมาฝากหน่อย
มีไหม
มีๆๆ
พี่เอกอยู่ไหนหรออยู่อยู่ตลาดใช่ไหมใช่
ๆๆ
เอาเท่าไหร่ 1 กิโลโอเคไหม
หมอแบบฝากแบบฝากแบบไม่จ่ายเงินได้ไหมอ่ะ
ได้
เคยเจออยู่ใช่ไหม
ไม่เป็นไรถ้าเป็นอาหารไม่เป็นไรแล้วก็ 1
กิโลโอเคแต่ถ้าซื้อมะม่วงมาฝากหน่อย 10
กิโลไม่ได้
10 กิโลกรัม
ไม่ได้นะคะมะม่วงก็ไม่ได้แพงมาก
ในราคาประมาณ
อ่าเอาว่าเท่าไหร่ก็ได้ไม่เกิน 300 บาท
เนาะ
ใช่อันนี้หมายถึงว่าซื้อมาฝากหน่อยนะไม่
เกิน 300 บาท
ถ้าเกิดว่า 500 บาท 1,000 บาท 2,000 บาท
อันนี้
จ่ายเงินนะ
ถ้า 300 บาทใช่
ซื้อฝากได้ไม่มีปัญหาแต่ต้องที่ไทยนะคะ
แล้วก็เอ๋ไม่หนัก
ไม่หนักหรือว่าหนักแต่ว่าเดินออกมาแล้ว
เรียกแท็กซี่ได้อันนี้
ไม่มีปัญหาแต่ว่าถ้าที่ไทยที่กรุงเทพฯแต่
ถ้าเกิดว่า
จะไปเชียงใหม่
เดี๋ยวจะไปเที่ยวเชียงใหม่กับเรียมอย่าง
นี้สมมุตินะสมมุติครูเอ๋จะไป
ไปจากกรุงเทพฯไปเชียงใหม่เนาะ
จากกรุงเทพฯไปยังไงดีคะพี่ไปเชียงใหม่
รถไฟ
้
รถไฟก็ได้นะ
เครื่องบินก็ได้กรุงเทพฯไปเชียงใหม่
เจอกันกับเรียนที่เชียงใหม่
เราก็มีกระเป๋าแล้วใช่ไหม
แล้ว
มีคนบอกว่า
เชียงใหม่มีอะไรดี
มี
โต๊ะมีมีเตียงเตียง
นอน
ใช่
ค่ะเชียงใหม่มีค่ะเตียงนอนมีเตียงนอนเป็น
ไม้
ไม้ดีๆเตียงนอนดีๆฝากซื้อหน่อย
30,000 บาท
ถึงไหมถึงเนาะถึง 30,000 บาท 30,000 บาท
แบบนี้
โอเค
30,000 บาทต้องโอนเงินมานะ
แต่ว่าริมก็ไม่อยากไม่อยากไปดูเตียงนอน
น่ะพี่เอ๋เขาจะไปเที่ยวใช่ไหมใช่
[เพลง]
ไปเดินดูเนาะ
แล้วก็ไม่รู้เตียงอันไหนดีไม่ดีใช่ไหม
ไม่รู้เอะใจดำไหมแต่เอ๋จะบอกเดลิเวอรี่
เถอะ
เปิดเว็บไซต์แล้วก็ดูแล้วก็โทรศัพท์คุย
กับร้านเตียงนอนดีกว่าเพราะว่าถ้าเราไป
เที่ยว 3 วัน 4 วันแต่ต้องไปเดินดูเตียง
นอนนี่น่าจะดู
1 วันได้ไหมก็ไม่รู้ชอบไม่ชอบก็ไม่แน่ใจ
ใช่ไหมคะคือครูเอ๋จะไม่ชอบให้คนฝากซื้อ
อะไรที่มันแพง
อันนี้จะไม่ค่อยชอบนะคะแต่ว่าถ้าฝากซื้อ
ที่อยู่ในกรุงเทพฯได้แต่ที่แพงเนี่ยไม่
รับฝากทำไมรู้ไหม
ทำไมคะพี่เมื่อก่อนนี้มีคนฝากซื้อกล้อง
วีดีโอ
ตอนนั้นพี่เอกไปที่ไหนคะพี่เอกไม่ได้ไป
ด้วย
จริง
อันนี้เรื่องจริงเลย
มีคน
ฝากซื้ออันนี้วีดีโอเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อน
ยังไม่มีโทรศัพท์ที่ที่ถ่ายวีดีโอได้
กล้องถ่ายรูปกับถ่ายวีดีโอเนี่ย
จะแพงแล้วก็แยกกันด้วยนะ
แล้วก็ไม่ใช่ดิจิทัลใช่ไหมต้องเป็นเทปน้ำ
แล้ว
แล้วราคา
ถ้าจำไม่ผิดประมาณ 23,000 บาท
ประมาณนะคะนักเรียน
ประมาณครูเอกก็จำไม่ได้ทีนี้เนี่ยเขาก็
ถามว่าอ้อเป็นครูใช่ไหมมีนักเรียนญี่ปุ่น
ที่สนิทกันไหมสนิทกันก็คือเป็นเพื่อนกัน
เอกก็บอกว่ามีทำไมเขาบอกว่าวิดีโอที่
ญี่ปุ่นน่ะกล้องถ่ายวีดีโอที่ญี่ปุ่นไม่
แพงที่ไทยแพง
เขาก็ดูมาให้แล้วบอกช่วยฝากนักเรียนซื้อ
ได้ไหมอันนี้
อันนี้คนไทย
อันนี้นักเรียน
ไม่รู้เอ๋เกรงใจนักเรียน
แต่ปรากฏว่า
นักเรียน 1 คนเป็นเพื่อนกันก็บอกเอ๋จะ
กลับญี่ปุ่นซื้ออะไร
มีคนอยากได้
กล้องวีดีโอฝากซื้อได้ไหมแต่มันจะหนักนะ
เขาก็บอกไม่เป็นไร
เอ๋ก็ถามเงินเท่าไหร่เดี๋ยวเอ๋ให้เอ๋บอก
คนนี้สำหรับให้คนนี้เขาก็ไว้ใจเอ๋เขาบอก
ไม่เป็นไร
[เพลง]
ซื้อมา
เองก็
ต้องให้เข้าใจเงินใช่ไหม
วันนี้ก็ต้องให้เงิน
เงินเขาเป็นเงินบาท
เป็นเงินบาทให้ไป 28,000
ทีนี้พอให้เงินไปเสร็จแล้ว
อีก 3 วัน
คนนี้โทรศัพท์บอกเอ๋ไม่อยากได้
แต่ว่าซื้อแล้ว
ใช่
ไม่อยากได้อยากได้อันอื่น
แต่อันนี้ซื้อตรงที่เขาจะเอานะคืน
เขาบอกว่าคืนให้คนนี้
คือได้ไหม
ถ้ามันไม่ใช่ในประเทศไทยไง
เอามาจากญี่ปุ่น
แล้วส่งไปเขาบอกว่าคือได้เงินคืนนิดหน่อย
โอเคมันมีรุ่นใหม่
อยากได้รุ่นใหม่
อันนี้ไม่วันนี้ไม่ใหม่แล้ว
เขาก็บอกลดราคาได้ไม่เป็นไรแต่คืน
แล้วเขาก็แบบเองมันไม่ได้เขาก็มีคนนี้มี
พูดไม่ดี complain
บอกไม่อันนี้มันไม่มีอันนี้อันนี้ที่ไทย
จะมีมีอะไรกระเป๋ามี
แล้วตรงนี้เป็นภาษาญี่ปุ่นไม่มีภาษาไทย
ก็ซื้อที่ญี่ปุ่น
ก็เลยตัดสินใจโอเคไม่เป็นไร
[เพลง]
เอก็ถามคนนี้นะ
คืนได้ไหมวันนี้ก็บอกว่าไม่ได้เพราะว่า
ตอนนี้อยู่ประเทศไทยไม่ได้กลับใช่ไหมแล้ว
มันก็เลยเวลา
เพราะเขาต้องซื้อมา
แล้วก็รอเวลาแล้วก็มาประเทศไทยถ้าไม่ชอบ 7
วันคืนได้แต่ตอนนี้มันเกิน 7 วันนะคะ
งั้นครูเอ๋จ่ายเงิน
ให้คุณ
แล้วเขารับไหมคะรับค่ะ
แล้วกล้องล่ะคะพี่
เอ๋หรอ
เอ๋ก็ไม่ได้ใช้
งาน
[เพลง]
ก็เลย
ตั้งแต่วันนั้นก็เลยบอกตัวเองว่าไม่รับ
ฝากซื้อ
คือถ้าซื้อก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ซื้ออาหารโอเคแต่
ถ้าซื้อที่มันแพงไม่รับนะคะไม่รับเพราะ
ว่า
ไม่ได้เงินนะ
เอ๊ะเสียเวลา
แล้ว
ก็ต้องฟังอะไรไม่ดีแล้วเอ๋ก็เสียเงินเอก
ก็เลยไม่เอาถ้าคิดจะซื้อไปซื้อกับคนเขามี
คนที่คนที่
มีอาชีพรับฝากซื้อ
ใช่แต่เขาบวกนะคะบวกกี่เปอร์เซ็นต์ไม่รู้
เขาบวกบวกบวกเปอร์เซ็นต์แล้วก็บวกอะไรนะ
บวกค่าอัดค่าส่งใช่ไหมคะ
เขาก็จะบวกเปอร์เซ็นต์แล้วก็บวกรถ
ค่าส่ง
อันนี้ดีกว่านะ
ค่าส่งก็ส่งเอง
เปอร์เซ็นต์ก็ไม่ได้บวกบางทีลดให้
แต่เจอแบบนี้ก็ไม่เอานะ
[เพลง]
ก็เลยไม่ค่อย
อะไรนะคะก็เลยแบบไม่ค่อยอยากรับ
ฝากซื้ออะไรอย่างนี้ไม่ๆๆไม่ค่อยรับฝาก
ซื้อแล้วก็ไม่ค่อยอยากฝากซื้อสมมุติว่า
เรียนจะไปอเมริกา
ค่ะ
ก็เตรียมจะไปเที่ยวและ
อยากได้กรรไกร
กรรไกร
ตัดผมที่อเมริกา
โอเคไหม
ถ้าเกิดเป็นเพื่อนเพื่อนที่สนิทกัน
แล้วเตรียมรู้รู้ว่าต้องไปซื้อไปซื้อที่
ไหน
เดี๋ยวมันก็จะอ้อโอเครู้ว่ากรรไกรอันนี้
แบบซื้อง่ายๆก็โอเค
ฝากซื้อนาฬิกาอันนี้ของญี่ปุ่นใส่กล่อง
ฝากซื้อนาฬิกา
Rolex หรือถ้าเรียนไปญี่ปุ่นฝากซื้อ
นาฬิกา Seiko โอเคไหมคะ
ไม่จะไปเที่ยวจะไปเดินจะไปถ่ายรูป
ไม่ช้อปปิ้งไม่ช้อปปิ้งแต่ว่า
อะไรคะเรียนไปนะมีแค่พ่อกับแม่
แล้วก็แบบเพื่อนๆน้อยๆคนที่รู้
เรียนไปแล้วก็กลับมาเรียนถึงแบบโพสต์รูป
ใน Facebook
[เพลง]
เลย
มีคนบอกว่า
ฝากซื้อนาฬิกาหน่อย
ราคาประมาณ 30,000 บาท
โอนเงินมาก่อนได้ไหม
ถ้าซื้อมาแล้วไม่เอาใครจ่ายเงิน
ก็ไม่ได้อยากได้นาฬิกาใช่ไหมคะแต่แบบ
นาฬิกายี่ห้อนี้แหละค่ะนาฬิกาดีนะคะแต่
ถ้าซื้อมาแล้วคุณไม่เอา
ก็ไม่ได้อยากได้สีนี้อยากได้อีกสีนึงอะไร
แบบนี้แล้วตอนนั้นเขาโอนเงินไปให้พี่เอก
ไม่ๆๆๆเขาไม่โอนเงิน
เขาบอกซื้อมาให้ก่อนไม่ได้ค่ะ
มีอีกคนนึงฝากซื้อกิโมโน
22,000
2,000  290 บาท
อันนี้
ที่ญี่ปุ่นน่ะ
เป็นกิโมโน
ใหม่เนี่ยร้านค้า
ถ้ามือสองประมาณประมาณ 80,000 บาท
[เพลง]
เป็นกิโมโนจริงๆเลยนะแบบมีครบทุกๆอะไรนะ
ทุกๆครั้ง
คือกิโมโนไม่ใช่ชิ้นเดียวใช่ไหมจะมีชิ้น
ข้างใน
นะ
คะก็อันนี้ก็จะต้องมีมีให้ครบทุกชิ้นนะคะ
ก็เขาบอกฝากซื้อกิโมโน
ไม่มี
ทำไมฝากไม่ได้ไม่มีเงิน
หลักแสนสำหรับช้อปปิ้ง
อ๋อเขาโอนมาไหมคะแบบไม่เขาไม่โอนเขาก็เลย
บอกว่าโอเคงั้นเปลี่ยนเป็น
โอเคฝากซื้อได้เขาก็ถามกันเท่าไหร่อ๋อ
อยู่กะตะถูกสุดประมาณ 3,500
[เพลง]
3,500
เอาไหม
เขาก็บอกอ๋อเขามี 500 บาท
เอ๋จ่ายให้ 3,000 ได้ไหม
ไม่ใช่เพื่อนสนิทนะคะไม่ใช่สนิทแต่ว่าพอ
รู้ว่า
จะกลับประเทศไทยเขาก็เลยฝากซื้ออันนี้ไม่
ได้นะคะนักเรียนคือถ้าฝากซื้อคุณต้องจ่าย
เงินดังนั้นตอนนี้ที่ครูเอ๋ก็เลยเขียนว่า
ไม่รับฝากแต่จริงๆไม่รับฝากไม่ใช่แค่
เรื่องเงินแต่ว่ามันมีเรื่องน้ำหนักอย่าง
นี้
ฝากซื้อครบ
อยู่ที่ไหน
ให้เอาไปส่งที่ไหน
สมมุติเตรียมจะไปอเมริกาแล้วมีเพื่อนที่
อเมริกาฝากซื้อครบอันนี้ประมาณ 3
กิโลกรัม
[เพลง]
หิ้วไปได้ไหมคะยังคิดว่าซื้อที่อเมริกา
เถอะ
แล้วถ้าน้ำหนักเกิน 1 กิโลกรัม
1 กิโลกรัมคือประมาณเท่าไหร่อ่ะ 800 ได้
ไหม
ตอนนั้นของครูเอ๋ไปมัน
690 ประมาณนี้ที่ไทยนะคะที่ไทยถาดที่
ญี่ปุ่นรู้สึกจะ 800 ถ้าจำไม่ผิดนะคะแต่
ว่า
แล้วแต่ประเทศไม่เหมือนกันนะคะนักเรียน
ดังนั้นน้ำหนักเกินก็คือ 1 กิโลกรัมเรา
ต้องบวกเพิ่ม
หายต้องจ่ายเงินเพิ่มดังนั้นเนี่ยถ้าซื้อ
ครบตัวนี้ครบครบอันนี้ 400 บาท
บวกไปอีก 24
00 ก็คือครบอันนี้จะ 2,000 แปดร้อยบาท
[เพลง]
คุณซื้อครบอันนี้ที่ญี่ปุ่นที่ไหนก็อยู่
ที่ประมาณ 500 บาทที่ญี่ปุ่น
ดีกว่าไหม
ถูกกว่า
อย่าฝากเลยนะคะ
อย่าฝากเลยนะคะอะไรที่มันหนักนะคะเพราะ
ว่าคือน้ำหนักมันเกินแล้วเวลาที่น้ำหนัก
เกินมากๆคนที่หิ้วกระเป๋าอ่ะยังเอ๋เนี่ย
ที่ไม่รับฝากจริงๆเพราะว่าของเอ๋ก็หนัก
อยู่แล้วมีของแม่ของหลานของพี่พอหิ้วแล้ว
น้ำหนักเกินเอ๋ต้องจ่ายเงินแล้วที่สำคัญ
คือพอน้ำหนักเกิน
ครูเอ๋หน้าผ่าตัด
ผ่าตัด
[เพลง]
ผ่าตัดคือ
คือ
มี
ที่นี่
แล้วตรงนี้ผ่าตัด
เวลาหิ้วแล้วหนักๆเนี่ย
เวลาเจ็บทีต้องนอน 3 วัน
อันนี้คือสำคัญที่สุดเวลาที่มีคนฝากอะไร
แล้วน้ำหนักเกินแล้วมันเจ็บอ่ะบางทีมัน
ต้องหิ้วต้องยกแล้วตรงนี้ไม่หายสักที
เพราะมันจะฉีกแล้วมันพอน้ำหนักเกินปั๊ป
เนี่ยโอ้โหเดินไม่ได้ 3 วัน
บ่อยๆครูเอ๋ก็เลยตอนนี้ไม่รับฝากนะคะไม่
รับฝากแต่ถ้ามีเพื่อนสนิทแล้วเรารู้ว่า
เขาชอบอะไรจะโทรศัพท์หาเองบอกว่าเอาไหม
ใช่ไหมใช่คือจริงๆแล้วในการฝากซื้อต้องดู
ว่าเขาแข็งแรงไหม
ถ้าแข็งแรงฝากซื้อได้
หรือสนิทกันมากๆไหมต้องรู้ว่าเวลาที่คนไป
เที่ยวเขาอยากจะมีเวลาถ่ายรูปอยากจะมี
เวลาซื้อของให้คุณพ่อคุณแม่
ถ้าเราฝากซื้อใช่ไหมถ้าฝากซื้อเนี่ยแล้ว
คุณไม่ได้ให้เงินเข้าไปเขาจะมีเงินจำกัด
น้อยลงใช่เขาก็จะซื้อของตัวเองไม่ได้
คือไม่ใช่เอ๋ไม่เคยรับฝากนะคะเอ๋รับฝาก
แล้วเขาไม่เอาเอ๋ต้องจ่ายเงินเองหรือเคย
รับฝากเนี่ยคือฝากซื้อนาฬิกาเอ๋ไม่ซื้อ
เขาก็เลยฝากซื้อคิทแคท
ก็บอกแพงช่วยซื้อมาให้หน่อยแต่เอาเยอะๆ
ก็ซื้อมาให้เยอะนะซื้อไปประมาณโอนเงินไป
ให้พี่เอ๋ไหมไม่ๆๆไม่โอน
ประมาณประมาณ 1,000 บาทที่ซื้อมา
พันกว่าๆ
เราก็บอกว่าจะมารับเอก็
หิ้วคิทแคทไป
ที่ทำงาน
อากาศร้อนด้วยนะไม่มาเอกก็ต้องหิ้วกลับ
บ้าน
เพราะว่าที่ทำงานไม่มีตู้เย็นใช่ไหมมีตู้
เย็นแต่ว่าตู้เย็นเต็มก็ไว้ไว้ตู้เย็นไว้
ตู้เย็นตู้เย็นก็มีของเยอะๆเขาก็โทรศัพท์
บอกว่าเดี๋ยวจะไปที่บ้านเอกก็หิ้วคิทแคท
ไปที่บ้าน
เสร็จแล้วเขาก็โทรศัพท์เดี๋ยวจะไปออฟฟิศ
ก็หิวคิทแคทไปออฟฟิศเป็นอยู่แบบนี้
ประมาณ
30 วัน
ใน 30 วันนี้ไม่ได้เจอกันเลยหรอคะ
ไม่ได้เจอแล้วก็โกรธ
หิ้วไปหิ้วกับหิ้วไปหิ้วกลับคิทแคทละลาย
ที่ประเทศไทยแค่เรียนเข้าเซเว่นไปซื้อออก
มา
ริมจะกินริมจับก็เอาละลายแล้วคิคแทคละลาย
แล้วแล้วเขามาเนี่ย
คิดเงินยังไงคะ
มันไม่สวยแล้วไงข้างในอ่ะ
ไม่รับฝากค่ะ
โอเวอร์โหลดให้เพราะว่าอันนี้หนักประมาณ
ครึ่งกิโลได้มั้งคะแล้วน้ำหนักเกินเอกก็
จ่ายเงินให้น้ำหนักเกินน่ะก็จ่ายเงินนะคะ
จริงๆคนไทยก็พูดโหลดเนาะ
น้ำหนักเกินก็ได้ overload ก็ได้เหมือน
กัน
อย่างน้ำหอมเนี่ย
ไม่รับฝากเลย
เพราะว่า
เพราะว่าถ้ามันแตก
หรือว่าโดนเช็คใช่ไหม
อันนี้มีซื้อได้ 1 ขวดใช่ไหมคะค่ะถ้าเกิด
ว่าเราก็อยากซื้อแล้วถ้ามีคนฝากซื้อมา
ปั๊บเขาตรวจอ้าต้องจ่ายภาษีสี
กี่เปอร์เซ็นต์คะ
ไม่รู้สิ
ยังไม่เคยซื้อให้ใครต้องจ่ายภาษีนี่
ใครจ่าย
ก็ไม่รู้ใช่ตัวเองน่ะโอเคจ่ายภาษีก็โอเค
นะแต่ถ้าเกิดซื้อให้คนอื่นแล้ว
ซื้อให้พี่เอ๋
ถ้าเกิดเตรียมเอาให้ไปเลยก็โอเคแต่ถ้า
เกิดพี่เอกฝากฝากซื้อ
มันมีภาษีด้วยนะอ้าวทำไมเมียนึกว่าซื้อ
แล้วถูกกว่าประเทศไทย
ก็เผอิญว่าเขาเช็คแล้วเขาเก็บ
แต่ว่าหนูจ่ายไปแล้วอ่ะ
ทะเลาะกัน
ไม่ฝากดีกว่านะคะนักเรียนเพื่อนจะไป
เที่ยวก็ให้ไปเที่ยวเถอะ
แต่ถ้าซื้อฝากโอเคถ้าเขาโทรหาแล้วบอกเออ
เรียมพี่อยู่สวิตเซอร์แลนด์นะ
แล้ว
มันมีน้ำหอม
พี่ยังไม่ซื้อแล้วก็กระเป๋าพี่ไม่มีอะไร
เตรียมเอาไว้
ถ้าอย่างนี้โอเค
ใช่ค่ะหรือว่าเราไปเที่ยวแล้วเห็นของบาง
อย่างแล้วก็อุ้ยนึกถึงพี่เอกซื้อไปฝากพี่
เอ๋ดีกว่าแบบนั้นก็ดีกว่าสบายใจสบายใจ
กว่านะคะคือบางทีก่อนก่อนจะฝากใครซื้อนะ
คะเราต้องถามเขาก่อนว่าเอ้ยมีเงินพอไหม 2
มีของนะ
หนักไหม
3 ร่างกายเขาแข็งแรงที่จะหิ้วไว้ 4 มี
เวลาไหม
ใช่ถ้าเกิดมีคนโทรมาถามเลยว่าแล้วสะดวก
ไหมอืมสะดวกไหมถ้าเกิดไม่สะดวกไม่เป็นไร
นะไม่เอาก็ได้
คือต้องรู้ 4 อย่างนี้ก่อนนะคะไม่ใช่บอก
อยู่เชียงใหม่
หรอซื้อนาฬิกา Rolex ให้หน่อย
ไม่ได้นะเพราะว่าเรื่องเรื่องราคาเงินอีก
เวลาเราฝากแล้วเราไม่เอาเงินไปให้เขาอ่ะ
คือต้องถามว่าราคามันกี่ดอลลาร์มันกี่เยน
มันกี่ยูโรใช่ไหมคะเราต้องให้เงินเข้าไป
เลย
ใช่ค่ะพี่เอ๋ก็ต้องรับด้วยนะ
เรื่องฝากซื้อเป็นเรื่องปวดหัวปวดหัวมาก
ริมก็เลยไปเที่ยวกลับมาทุกคนทุกๆคนถึงจะ
รู้ว่าอ๋อเรียนไปเชียงใหม่มา
ไม่อยากรับโทรศัพท์ฝากซื้อของใช่ไหมคะไม่
ค่ะถ้าเกิดเรียนอยากซื้อมาฝากแต่เรียม
ซื้อมาให้เองใช่ซื้อฝากดีกว่าค่ะเอ๋ก็
ซื้อฝากเองหรือว่าถ้าอะไรที่ไม่หนักเอ๋ก็
ซื้อฝากได้หรือว่าฝากซื้อได้แต่ให้เอก
โทรศัพท์หานะ
เพราะว่าเราจะซื้อให้เฉพาะคนที่สนิทเนาะ
สนิทจริงๆแล้วก็ถ้าไม่สนิทไม่สนิทก็บ้าน
ใกล้ๆ
ถ้าบ้านใกล้ๆโอเคซื้อมาเสร็จให้ได้เลย
ไม่ต้องรอ 30 วัน
ใช่แล้ว
โอเคนักเรียนล่ะคะชอบไหมคะเวลามีคนฝาก
ซื้อของ
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ซื้อฝากนะ
ฝากซื้อนะ
ชอบไหมหรือว่าแบบ
แบบเวลาที่คนซื้อของมาฝาก
หรือว่านักเรียนชอบซื้อของไปฝากใคร
แบบนั้นหรือเปล่านะคะก็สามารถคอมเมนต์ได้
ครูเอ๋ชอบซื้อของไปฝากแต่ไม่ชอบให้คนฝาก
ซื้อเตรียมก็เหมือนกันค่ะเตรียมก็ชอบซื้อ
ของไปฝากแต่ก็ไม่ชอบให้คนฝากซื้อไม่ชอบ
นักเรียนชอบแบบไหนหรือไม่ชอบแบบไหน
comment ข้างล่างนะคะได้ค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้
เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะพี่
[เพลง]
เจอกันในคลิปหน้านะคะถ้าได้ค่าบ๊ายบายค่ะ
น้องเรียมบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]